in the Baltic Sea bubbles caused by a
mega underwater gas leak filmed by the
Danish military the gas is escaping from
three points on Russia's nordstream
Pipelines
the mysterious damage seemingly
happening just hours apart the result of
a free coincidence the Polish prime
minister doesn't think so
we do not yet know the details of what
happened at nordstream but we can
clearly see that it is an act of
sabotage an act that probably marks the
next stage in the escalation of the
situation we are dealing with in Ukraine
once a main source of energy for Europe
since the war in Ukraine Russia's been
accused of using its gas pipelines to
Blackmail the EU after slashing flows
through nordstream one since the summer
earlier this month it indefinitely cut
off supplies blaming technical problems
the pipelines run more than a thousand
kilometers under the Baltic Sea to
Germany the first leak was reported on
the never opened nordstream two line on
Monday east of the island of born home
then on Tuesday two leaks were found on
the nearby nordstream one with Swedish
scientists detecting explosions we know
very well what an underwater blast looks
like and so in this case there's no
doubt this is not an earthquake this is
a blast that has been occurring in the
water column or close to the bottom
the cause of the damage is still being
investigated Ukraine's accuse Russia of
a terrorist attack while Moscow says
it's making its own inquiries also
claiming the pipelines have been
deliberately destroyed while experts are
speculating what could have caused this
damage convinced this was the result of
a deliberate act Denmark will meet the
NATO chief on Wednesday to discuss the
leak if sabotage is confirmed here that
could Mark a new and serious escalation
in the energy War raging alongside the
conflict in Ukraine Siobhan Robbins Sky
News Germany